[Musique]
cousin de l'ancien venu ici un maximum
ce qui est votre commune maxime est
revenu à un bon exemple pour le café
politique vous êtes première adjointe et
donc de montigny le bretonneux vous est
aussi vice-présidente de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en charge des
ressources humaines et de la politique
de la ville voilà pour débuter on va
revenir sur votre implication au sein de
cette commune parce que je vous ai
entendu dire à l'instant vous êtes là
depuis longtemps
le premier mandat élections 89 89 60
assure sur la liste de nicolas à bout en
bonne position
qu'est-ce qui vous avez travaillé
franchir le pas à vous engager sa vie
c'est pas ce qui s'y passe voir en fait
on est arrivé à montigny fin 82 et puis
je me suis carrément franchi le pas de
prendre une
une carte politique de mme encartés
comme on dit et
voilà parce que c'était les années enfin
c'était 80 à la naissance de ma deuxième
fille génération mitterrand etc et donc
et donc vous avez pris votre carte
politique
oui ok ok au centre quel parti direct
j'ai fait après génération mitterrand
d'être voilà et donc et donc par
conséquent à gérer concrétiser ce que je
pensais depuis longtemps franchissant
pas de dedans de mon kart et where perd
effectivement qui naissaient qui
naissait sur cette ville
et donc très vite j'ai pris la
présidence et 2
de la section rpr parce que c'est ainsi
que ça se nommait voyager parce que
oubliés de la section et repère locale
et puis à la demande aussi de quelques
élus versaillais départementaux et puis
voilà nicolas boulay là du coup être
vraiment avec des options et des
opinions bien marquer quand même et ça
n'est pas une tare et donc voilà il a
demandé c'est ce que j'étais
la cheftaine du secteur vous êtes resté
à montigny le bretonneux
c'est avec le maire suivent ensuite avec
michel et logiciels et d'ailleurs comme
michel laugier a quitté la municipalité
suite à son élection au sénat on a
évoqué votre nom aussi profond avec
documents donc voila mais pour des
raisons diverses et variées on a n'ai
pas de regret de ne pas avoir occupé ce
poste
non mais j'ai pas d'abord dans la vie
j'ai pas de jeu pas pour habitude
d'avoir des regrets déjà tout ce qu'on
fait c'est un choix personnel finalement
personne n'a le pouvoir de nous obliger
à quoi que ce soit et donc par
conséquent
voilà ça me convient très bien je
connais jean luc depuis presque autant
d'années que perdre des années vous avez
décroché un poste de vice présidente à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cette nouvelle
tâche vous convient aussi c'est toute
interruption alors là je suis ravi pour
ne rien vous cacher au niveau de la
politique de la ville non pas sur le
plan local mais globalement parlant
j'avais quelques a priori dans la mesure
où je me dis ça fait quand même 25 ans
qu'on essaie de faire des choses dans le
cadre de la politique de la ville et que
malheureusement on avance peut-être pas
aussi bien qu'on espérait pouvoir
avancer aidé en l'occurrence d'une fois
effectivement qu'on est plus proche des
choses d'une part je travaille avec des
gens très professionnels est vraiment
formidable qui se donne beaucoup de mal
et puis on va un disque il ya des choses
à faire
la société a évolué le plus voilà vous
le savez on est dans une période
compliquée au niveau même internationale
et donc donc et par conséquent il ya
tout à fait des nécessités et je suis
ravi d'avoir ces deux postes
vous parlez de poste ce poste mais avec
ces deux délégations
vous parliez tout à l'heure de vos idées
bien affirmée donc idées de droite
aujourd'hui le regard que vous portez
sur votre famille politique et est ce
que vous faites partie des élus qui vont
renouveler ou pas alors leur cap leur
adhésion mais je vais tout à fait
honnête avec vous je n'ai pas renouvelé
je n'ai pas aujourd'hui mais je suis
très triste de ce qui se passe je reste
complètement attaché à ma famille
politique les options prises ne me
conviennent pas on ne verrait pas à ce
qui est proposé est ce que représente
aujourd'hui elle avoue qu'elle préside
en fonctionnement
voilà mais c'est vraiment une grande
tristesse parce que quand on a passé des
années à soutenir sans quoi on croyait
donc pour l'instant j'en suis là je
crois beaucoup en je crois beaucoup en
valérie pécresse
mais bon j'ai fait mon chemin je ne me
précipite pas pour l'instant bien
qu'aujourd'hui on vous classe à droite
divers droite on va dire en fait divers
droite j'aime trop ça parce que ça veut
dire quoi
oui voilà on va dire non non je reste
vraiment apparentés voilà je préfère ça
à part au travers on attend de voir
comment en attendant comment les choses
ont évolué pour autant il ya des figures
de droite peut-être qu'ils vous ont
inspiré et engagé par lés tout à leur
génération mitterrand ça vous convenait
pas et des faiseurs de droite plutôt
qu'il vaut qu'on pouvait alors pourquoi
ça ne me convenait pas d'abord parce que
on a tous notre histoire personnelle la
mienne était d'être né au sein d'une
famille
tout à fait dévoué à son pays mes oncles
ont fait la guerre mais encore été
emprisonné et cetera donc avait vraiment
un passé qui m'a marqué puisque toute
cette histoire je vais entendu bien
évidemment on était enfant et puis la
famille était gaulliste
alors vous me direz c'est pas parce que
on a une famille gaulliste qu'on doit
voir moi j'ai vu aussi avec les enfants
après tout moi avec une de mes filles
qui a abandonné d'abord n'était pas
intéressé par la politique et du coup ne
partagent pas forcément les options mais
c'est bien ça mais ça met du rythme dans
la discussion
et donc voilà il y avait il y avait ce
passé et puis et puis oui il ya des vous
me parliez des figures qui m'ont marqué
ah oui ça reste tout d'abord il ya
jacques chirac de gaulle bien sûr voilà
mes jacques chirac avec
voilà tout ce qu'il a tout ce qu'il a pu
faire toute l'énergie qu'il a déployés
et la plus belle campagne que j'ai vécu
7 et celle de 95g pas été la seule
d'ailleurs parce qu'on était des
milliers et des milliers et ça a été ça
a été une superbe campagne vous avez
l'occasion de le rencontrer
petitement petitement mais parfois on
sert plus rester après la défaite de 88
effectivement j'ai eu la chance un soir
d'être dans une réunion
nous étions peu nombreux et puis après
on quand on préparer la campagne de 95
ya eu aussi un autre lieu un dîner aussi
nous étions peu nombreux à rambouillet
en l'occurrence puisqu'on avait fait le
tour avec voilà avec aussi ses
plaisanteries importante et intéressante
parce que ça vous sortez un petit peu du
lot des choses et puis un autre une
autre personne qui m'a beaucoup marqué
c'est fini c'est bien voilà j'ai jeu
malheureusement la vie a voulu que il
nous quitte très vite mais non seulement
je crois que j'en suis sûre il avait
compris beaucoup de choses
il avait compris comment s'allier à des
partenaires parlent toujours évident
mais pour faire avancer pour faire
avancer les choses
et puis surtout sa définition c'était de
n'avoir aucun sectarisme et ça pour moi
c'est très important parce qu'il faut
pas partir du principe que si quelqu'un
a une carte ailleurs que la vôtre
forcément ces idées sont mauvaises et
toujours de bonnes idées
j'ai tout le monde
tous ceux qui justement ont franchi le
pas de prendre une carte politique ont
de vraies convictions
voilà où alors bon c'est que c'est que
ça sert à rien mais je ne pense pas
quand même et donc les gens qui ont une
vraie conviction ils sont importants
qu'ils aient une carte dont je vous le
disais au pc ps ou etc
et ça c'est très important et j'avais
beaucoup aimé
justement cette idée de ne pas être
sectaire et ça je h2 revendique de jeu
c'est vraiment comme parfois comme tout
le monde je peux dire ap mais
j'essaie de faire en sorte que de ne pas
être envahi par sa surtout pas et puis
par contre j'attends la même chose ceux
qui sont en face de moi tout de même et
vos convictions vous les avez fait
entendre au cours de différents mandats
puisque vous avez été conseillère
régionale aussi vous avez été aussi la
supplante de françois de mazières
en tant que députée suppléante
détiennent auparavant lui aussi maire de
versailles
vous avez eu envie de siéger à
l'assemblée un moment mais bon si vous
étiez suppléante à chaque fois à réagir
face à villa titulaire sur ce poste
avait tout à fait ben oui vous savez on
a une complication sur cette
circonscription c'est qu'on a le gros
poids lourds qui versailles
et puis mon client est
et donc c'est vrai que au niveau du
nombre d'électeurs forcément plus
d'électeurs à versailles qu'il y en a un
bon team aiguille encore réunies donc le
choix toujours été fait ainsi vous avez
dû vous ranger derrière avec plaisir
ah j'avais vraiment rien ni au contraire
ce sont deux personnes que j'aime
beaucoup mais genre alors j'aurais pu
j'aurais pu voilà avec des si on refait
le monde
en 97 vous souvenez qu'il ya une
dissolution
ça s'est passé tout à fait comme ça que
ça se passe
voilà mais là c'est vrai qu'il y avait
comme un dire une ouverture aimeriez
mais cga à l'assemblée c'est à dire que
ce sera votre regret même s'il avoue dit
tout à l'heure vous en obtenant n'aviez
pas mes regrets politique de ne pas
avoir réussi à siéger au national parce
que l'action locale c'est important mais
au national sur lequel est importante à
leur mettre dans la loi a changé on ne
peut plus mais cumulées de choses
pourquoi pas c'est pour ça que
fonctionne nazir d'ailleurs a fait le
choix de versailles en plutôt que de la
députation
moi je crois profondément qu'il faut
garder un pied dans lequel on ne peut
pas s'éloigner et être conscient de tout
ce que le gens peuvent vivre
si si on n'est pas censé savoir alors je
sais bien que les députés sur là pour
faire les lois qui sait mais on fait
avancer les lois parce que on sait de
quoi on parle voilà donc regardé nicolas
bour lorsqu'il a fait la loi sur le
handicap
il savait pertinemment parce que vous
avez des exemples parce qu'on avait
construit les choses ici à montigny de
manière à prendre justement en compte
toutes les difficultés que peuvent
rencontrer les personnes handicapées et
donc voilà c'est vraiment basé sur son
expérience locale voire mais bon c'est
pas un grand regret non plus j'ai fait
d'autres choses
oui si on fait un point sur les actions
aussi en local si vous deviez faire un
bilan de ce que vous n'allez plus faire
de quoi vous êtes le plus fier ou
satisfaite en tout cas
alors parce qu'à des actions qui vous
ont marqué oui oui donc depuis un peu
plus de vingt ans je m'occupe de la vie
scolaire et est donc en 95 on avait
lancé j'avais emmené un groupe à epinal
etc etc puisque philips et bien les mis
en place l'aménagement du temps de
l'enfant ce qui n'était pas tout à fait
ce qu'on a vécu il ya un an et demi est
donc là oui c'était ça a été un énorme
travail un travail fabuleux
il fallait convaincre mais là on voyait
bien qu'on était venu trop tôt dans un
monde trop vieux ou voilà enfin quelque
chose comme ça mais il y avait il y
avait vraiment beaucoup de difficultés à
faire un médecin et ça c'est un regret
mais globalement parlant pas pas
simplement pour la ville de montigny
c'est un regret dans la mesure où je
pense que là encore philippe séguin
avait visé juste
c'est à dire que c'était vraiment ça
aurait été créateur d'emplois moi je les
ai vus à epinal créateurs d'emplois
puisque du coup là déjà la journée était
complètement réorganisé
toutes les structures qu'une ville peut
posséder et elle a aussi mis à
disposition par a
et donc là on était dans un autre tout à
fait dans un autre cas de figure on
n'était pas non plus comme l'allemagne
qui s'arrêtait à midi et puis après il
ya plus rien ne s'était passé
buts et est donc je pense que la wii on
a on a un peu raté le coche vraiment et
c'est dommage et c'est dommage on a
beaucoup parlé politique depuis tout à
l'heure pour terminer peut-être cette
cette émission votre engagement
politique occupe une part importante de
votre vie mais vous avez d'autres
passions d'autres engagements
ma famille c'est important ma famille
mes petites filles maintenant donc voilà
d'autres passions oui j'aime bien dire
j'aime bien les émissions j'aime bien
les émissions mais je dois dire
politique parce que je ne vis que ce
soit moi j'aime bien les débats
j'aime bien tout ce qui concerne
l'histoire aussi et en particulier
l'histoire un peu contemporaine
voilà toutes celles qui rappellent aussi
qu'il ya des gens qui si nous sommes là
tranquillement ce matin on fait en sorte
qu'on puisse l'être
et qu'est ce que j'aime d'autres vos
journées merci beaucoup susan barr
tunisie à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
d'avoir participé à ce rendez merci
beaucoup
[Musique]